le mot résilience qu'on entend beaucoup
dans le jargon de l'action climatique
veut d'abord dire résistance aux chocs
d'un matériau pour absorber le choc du
dérèglement du climat les villes doivent
s'adapter la ville doit être plus
communéponge on peut pas la minéraliser
le ruissellement de l'eau sur des
surfaces imperméables doit diminuer
Boucherville vient de recevoir une
attestation d'excellence pour avoir
conçu un vaste stationnement
éco-responsable il y en mille packs donc
on a non seulement des pavés drainants
on va aussi avoir des pavés alvéoliques
on a des nouveaux végétalisés que des
caissons qui vont filtrer l'eau jusqu'à
la sortie qui va après dans un autre
bassin de rétention
la première des priorités pour
l'adaptation des villes selon cette
chercheuse c'est verdir nos
infrastructures donc c'est les routes
les infrastructures d'eau pluviales donc
c'est les verres pour les adeptes au
changement climatique mais avoir des
coûts bénéfices pour les soins citoyens
en terme de qualité de vie comme cette
initiative qui s'inspire d'une place
inondable à Rotterdam au Pays-Bas
un parc résilient à Montréal aire de
jeux de pique-nique et de promenade 95%
du temps et en cas de fortes pluies
donc c'est des centaines de mètres cubes
là c'est l'équivalent de 30 pc notaires
là qui viennent s'accumuler
temporairement plutôt que de continuer
leurs courses puis d'aller
éventuellement inonder les bâtiments les
îlots de chaleur sont un autre défi en
ville depuis 2011 obligation dans
l'arrondissement Rosemont que les toits
neufs ou rénovés soient blancs ne sont
pas foncée au soleil on dit que elle
peut atteindre la température 50 à 50
degrés plus haute que la température de
l'air tandis qu'une surface blanche va
seulement atteindre 10 degrés de plus
que la température de l'air avec le même
objectif l’union européenne soutient le
projet cours oasis qui prévoit
déminéralisée toutes les cours d'école
de Paris
l'idée chemise ici cette école de
Longueuil vient de remplacer 1000 mètres
carrés d'asphalte mais il n'y a pas de
programme subventionné à grande échelle
autre idée qui pourrait être importée
Séoul qui avait asséché une rivière et
l'avait recouverte d'une route a décidé
de revenir aux sources pour faire plus
de place à la nature en ville
ici Mathieu Prost Radio-Canada Montréal